balancé balancé balancé balancé balancé
balancé balancé balancé balancé balancé
I get up super early generally I have
this thing where I like beating the Sun
up not just in terms of what sometimes I
have to get up and how do I do it like
it's just important to find balance and
I try and do things really that I really
enjoy doing and a lot of times you know
it's like in life right life brings like
drama and you're gonna deal with this
person and make your relationship here
do all these things you try and just
kind of balance them out as best I can
it's it's complex right and it's
deceiving mmm at times you know if
people think the to equate yes you know
to each other and they don't write you
don't have a lot of money it's up yeah
and then I don't have a lot of happiness
but that doesn't mean that the to equate
to each other as your happiness risen at
the same romano's your bank account no
that's the thing they don't they don't
they don't equate they're not as hide in
any way that tied to each other I mean
it allows you freedom and allows you to
go places where you could smile and look
at the sunset and things like that
that's what you choose to do in you
enjoy to do right but there are a lot of
people with tons of money who aren't
happy because they're either they've
become a prisoner of their money or
they've become so concerned with getting
money that they don't allow time for
happiness right life is about balance
right you have to have some type of
balance you have like time for work and
it's time for play and if you don't
allow these two things to co-exist you
have an imbalance I've wanted up both
Ryan and I are eight times I want to say
envious but but we look at other people
like you take Kendrick Kendrick is a
rapper Kendrick is in the studio right
now I guarantee it
he's not thinking about you know that
the merge design that we have right now
isn't fitting on it on a tank top the
way that it should it's true and
and that's a it's a blessing in the
curse you know we we both are have we
are the output in terms of anything
creative it it's a music video if it's
directing if it's writing a treatment if
it's if it's you know being a character
in the music video it we are everything
same thing with their merge same thing
with just the ideas that we have full
circle in terms of running a business so
that's taking away time that we could be
working on our specific grass producing
and rapping so I think that it's a
balance we both enjoy business we both
enjoy being holistically creative that's
a fulfilling thing I don't want to be in
the studio every single day all the time
I want to be picking fonts I want to be
you know with Ryan color editing a music
video that's something that we both
enjoy so it's a balance and I think that
we haven't we wear enough hats that we
can kind of bounce around and be
inspired but it comes at a sacrifice
yeah if you're really gonna be an artist
with your own voice and you want to do
different things and try you know not
the standard thing then you know the
biggest balancing act you have to pull
isn't really even being a good filmmaker
we'll just say that you have that is
that balancing act between sticking to
your vision sticking to your voice but
not being some [ __ ] that could only
hear the sound of his own voice you know
and that's I mean it's all right there
that's it you got to be able to listen
to people you got to be able to hear
what they're saying but you also can't
just I mean when the when the going gets
tough not give up on your vision
well I always sort of test my boys and
say okay I can be a stay-at-home mom
what do you think and they're like no no
no we don't want that
so I think that's kind of funny in a way
but I think my boys know they're my
first priority and I think it's about
how being a mother to me is the gift of
the world to me and but also being able
to have a company like this as well so I
think it's really about just figuring
out the balance and it's always going to
be a balance in my opinion having it all
and what all these people are talking
about now is a very individual question
I don't think that having it all means
everything to the same person so you
have to figure out what having it all is
for you I certainly had to give certain
things up things that I didn't mind
giving up but my family and my work came
first and that's sort of finding that
balance we got to incorporate in the
philosophy of our company the values the
real value statement of what we're all
about
the idea of work love and play to be
successful in life you have to have
three things in balance if not how would
you run a 24 hour day business if you
didn't have a balance in your life you
follow me I mean you have a nervous
breakdown if you're just a workaholic
wouldn't you so I think to be successful
you have to have all three and you'll be
more successful if you strive for
balance in your life you make better
decisions
somehow wives really ground the hell out
of you you're not a big shot at home
that's good so just try to remember make
goals every year for all three work love
and play and it's you know it's just
important you make better decisions you
imagine when I went out and I told these
people that loved things
let's go 24 hours a day what they would
say to me Paul I can't work any harder
does it how do you expect me to keep
this thing open 24 hours a day those are
the wrong people they had an idea of
going to people base people and you
can't lead other people unless you
manage yourself and if you don't look
rested nobody wants to follow a leader
that's tired Haggard and miserable I
mean it's just
prerequisite for leadership nobody wants
to I think Obama's done a bad job the
first month he looked too dour I agree
with B I voted for him if I agree with
Bill Clinton he is not yesterday was
inspirational but you don't want the
President of the United States saying if
you don't pass this legislation you go
off the cliff wrong he's got to always
be cheerful always uplifting that's what
leaders are supposed to do and then
somebody said well you don't want it you
wanted to be honest no you don't always
have to be honest as a leader you could
honestly say I know this problems over
there but we're still gonna charge
forward you don't have to the leadership
is a different thing it's not the open
kimono every time remember remember work
love and play you'll be successful
you'll be a better leader
you'll be a more balanced person and
people will respect you more so all you
workaholics drink some beer the hardest
job that I have a CEO is blending or
finding the right balance between like
empathy and and realism mm-hmm
I guess what I mean by that is you know
I have a few or a bunch of employees who
work me who haven't been at startups
this early you know don't necessarily
kind of understand things break all the
time and that sort of thing but you have
to still be empathetic about it because
you don't want them to give up but you
have to kind of offer a harsh dose of
realism like this is the way it happens
right yeah this is real life so that's
something that I've never had to really
balance before because I was just
playing business yeah right now I'm
playing with folks livelihood right
their children's health insurance right
yeah yeah I have to think about things
that I would have never thought so this
is the hardest job I've ever had in my
entire life right but the most rewarding
when you want to have balance you will
definitely have it you can have it know
what it just is I want to have balance
my life this thought itself is good
enough you have already balancing you
are moving in that direction yeah this
question simply arises how do I do it
you know you can do it ask yourself
your consciousness will tell you I am
not balanced I am missing out on this
your consciousness will say then you
listen to your consciousness if you are
attending to your work too much your
consciousness will prick he you're
forgetting your family you are a wife
your children your husband then you say
okay how are tend to them if you are
attaining too much immersed so much in
the family and forget about all other
things then your consciousness will
prick my god what am I got into what did
they get into they are not I am just
immersed in this family affairs I am NOT
being useful to the world I had to do
something I had to pursue my cause I had
to do justice to my work but my dear
prick then you do that but this wanting
to keep balance in life that very
thought is good enough it's like the
fuse in the electrical system you know
you know the fuse in the electrical
system whenever the electric current
surges too much the fuse will break and
saved everything else like that that
little amount of guilt must be there
like the fuse in the system
you don't justify your fall but that
little bit is okay to have like the fuse
in it
Electric you know about the electrical
system you know all that electrical
board there will be one small box called
fuse so whenever there is imbalance in
current the fuse will burst and save the
rest of the electrical system like that
in life a little bit of guilt should is
okay but not too much like salt in the
foot if there is too much salt can you
eat it no got it
so wanting to her balance is good to
have if we were to run into rain
conditions of this kind of
is there a better method ayrton for us
to look into how the race should be
stopped earlier or more positively we
shouldn't start but whose decision is
classier I think it's very hard for the
officials to make such a decision
because there is a lot of pressure
television all over the world and it's
difficult we understand but I think it's
in a way is our own fault
we should have started the drivers if we
just get out of the cars stick together
and make a decision for ourselves then
the race wouldn't start in first place
it's always very difficult to get it all
together I experienced it myself two
years ago today again because also we
have a lot of responsibility to the
teams and the sponsors that give us so
much and there are moments that we have
to also try to give them something but
he's very difficult to find the
equilibrium the balance on making the
right decisions at every single time I
want to share with you a piece of advice
that one of my mentors gave me a few
years ago he sat me down actually I was
already sitting he sat down next to me
and he said I get that you're struggling
right now I mean at the time I was going
through a problem and he said Sean you
got to remember this life is a delicate
balance from one end remaining flexible
and on the other hand enforcing your
boundaries and it was so simple that I
almost discarded it that advice just
sounded right click write flexible yet
boundaries and he further explained that
you gotta remain flexible life is going
to change on you but you also have to
enforce your boundaries you gotta let
other people know I am the universe know
what you will and will not tolerate and
he said if you get to was the words he
said if you get to flexible you can be
manipulated and walk
if you get too much in the space of
enforcing your boundary you'll become
cold hard and distant people aren't
gonna want to love you work with you
hang out with you you need a balance
when I looked at my life and I thought
well where am I
gravitating towards naturally well my
whole life I've had to remain flexible
I'm three feet on in a wheelchair I have
you know a condition by the time I
turned 18 I had fractured over 200 times
something like going to the airport on a
family vacation and I break my arm
putting my jacket on and now we can't go
you know all these things happen in my
life that forced me become flexible
handle whatever comes at you but when it
came to enforcing boundaries sometimes I
wasn't strong enough and sometimes I
would tolerate things in relationships
in business partnerships I didn't agree
with ready to rock the boat can you
relate but not everybody's like me some
people will get really good at enforcing
their boundaries making it very clear
what they will and won't tolerate they
have a hard time and you like you move
one little thing on their desk or you
change one thing about their life or you
need them to compromise on something and
they freak out
they can't handle uncertainty they can't
handle dealing with other people's
schedules whatever it may be they just
have a hard time being flexible with
life and you need to think about where
are you naturally gravitating because
it's time to move yourself more towards
the middle if you've gotten really good
at forcing your boundaries
congratulations that's awesome you're
not gonna be messed with but maybe
you're very hard to deal with or meeting
you're like the most flexible person on
earth everybody loves you you're the
nice girl a nice guy but you get walked
all over and you have no self respect
now
because you get manipulated and pushed
in or maybe you were one and then swung
the pendulum so far to the other side
that you've lost your original space the
goal is to find that center point it's
to find that I will get graceful dance
as my mentor called it the dance between
remaining flexible then forcing your
boundaries so next time you're having a
challenge with someone or in your own
life just by yourself ask yourself am I
too strict with my boundaries am i
laying down a lot too much and making it
uncomfortable for people to deal with me
or am I too flexible my too
accommodating to my making all kinds of
concessions and getting walked on or
abused figure out what is it for you
keep the two in balance in your life or
flow thank you guys so much for watching
I hope you enjoyed I'd love to know
which of the clips meant the most to you
had the biggest impact leave it in the
comments below I'll join the discussion
thank you for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon